check out this week's must-see movies  was the end of the world Batman and  Wonder Woman lead a newly formed team of  superheroes in Justice League witness  the story of the first Christmas to a  whole new set of eyes a small band of  animals become unexpected heroes in the  star there's something seriously wrong  with those animals he's a freak  there's anything that'll be mine a young  boy with facial differences faces new  challenges in wonder feel like you're  all see what's hot in theaters with this  week's fan tissa patient  [Music]  so what's your weekend ticket going to  be let us know by commenting see you  next time on weekend ticket  [Music]  you